Unlike recessive alleles, having two copies of every
gene does not protect you from a dominant allele.
As we learned in lesson five, having one
copy of a dominant allele is enough to cause
a phenotype. Now in the case of dwarfism,
the most common cause is a dominant allele that
causes Achondroplasia, which is inhibition in bone growth. Achondroplasia
is one of the most common causes of dwarfism.
So this is what normal bone growth looks like.
If we take a long bone from your body, the
end of it it has a particular kind of
cell, here I'm outlining it in red, that actually grows
and divides and then it comes into the long
bone part of the bone and it provides the material
that grows the bone longer over time. Now, those
red cells are red, indicating that they had a particular,
important protein called Fgfr3. It stands for fibroblast
growth factor receptor 3. And we'll learn a bit
more about it in a moment. But we'll just call it Fgfr3 for now, and as these
Fgfr3 positive cells grow and divide, then they
become the cells that are part of the, the
physical substance of the long bone itself. So, the
way the bone grows itself, essentially, is these Fgfr3
positive cells grow and divide into more cells,
and that's how the bone gets longer. Now,
how do bones end up a certain length,
and they're not shorter or longer? Well, it
turns out that this protein Fgfr3 is really important in regulating this
process, in fact, signalling through Fgfr3 in a cell keeps
the bone from growing too long. An active Fgfr3 protein prevents
bones from growing even longer, but some mutations
in the Fgfr3 gene, results in a protein
that's over active. And it actually stunts the
growth of bones even more, so that they
can't grow as long even as they normally would. So, let's learn a bit more about
this Fgfr3 protein. The Fgfr3 gene can be
found on chromosome four in the human genome.
Chromosome four has 186 million base pairs in it, and the Fgfr3 protein can be
found near the end. The Fgfr3 gene itself consists of
17 exons spanning 15,000 base pairs,
after transcription and splicing, the resulting mNRA
has 2,421 nucleotides of coding region.
And after translation, we'll have a protein
with 806 amino acids. Remember, we just divided
2,421 by three and then subtracted one from
the overall answer, because the last codon is
a stop codon, which doesn't code for an
amino acid, it's just empty. Now, let's actually
look at one allele of this gene that's
associated with Achondroplasia. One allele of the Fgfr3
gene contains a G to A, a guanine to
add new mutation at position 1138 of the coding region.
Now using the genetic code which we learned about in
lesson three, and you can find posted in the instructor's
notes on this page. I want you to determine the
change expected in the amino acid sequence here. And then
select the type of mutation best used to describe this
A allele from the list below. Now if you have
trouble answering this you want to go back and review mutations
from lesson six.